-Thank you. Thank you very much
and welcome to
"The Tonight Show,"
ladies and gentlemen.
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for watching at home.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Well, guys,
some big news from overseas --
yesterday, two Russian
fighter jets collided
with a U.S. surveillance drone
and sent it crashing
into the Black Sea, yeah.
The damage would've
been a lot worse,
but luckily, on its way down,
the drone bounced off a bunch
of Chinese spy balloons.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah, the whole thing
was pretty scary.
Meanwhile, the FAA was like,
"Cool, a plane collision
we can't be blamed for?
Love it!
Alright, hey, alright."
[ Laughter ]
Guys, listen to this --
despite all his controversies,
Congressman George Santos
has filed paperwork
to run for reelection in 2024.
-No.
[ Booing and ohhs ]
-We actually got our hands
on the paperwork that he filed.
-Oh, really?
Yeah, Look at this.
Check this out. It says...
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow!
[ Cheering ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
He signed it with a winky emoji.
That's --
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
-No!
-I don't know, just suspect.
Sus!
-A little sus.
-Hey, this is going viral --
earlier this week,
Rudy Giuliani was hosting
his nightly show
on the Internet.
He has a show on the Internet
and he seemed pretty confused
about a pretty well known event.
Watch this.
-Somebody asked me
about something called...
...Oscar?
[ Laughter ]
Oscar?
-Oh, the Oscars.
Oh, it's the O--
Oh, it's a family?
[ Laughter and applause ]
What are Os--
Some big thing happened last
night that I am called Oscar.
-It's called the Oscars.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
-"The -- The Grammys?
[ Laughter ]
My Grammy? My Grammy's been dead
for 20 years."
[ Laughter ]
Guys, some sports news today --
Aaron Rodgers said that,
next season, it is his intention
to play for the New York Jets.
[ Oohs and whistles ]
But let's not get too excited.
It was also my intention
to go to Harvard.
[ Laughter ]
It just didn't happen.
Yep, Aaron Rodgers could be
coming to New York.
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]
Jets fans were like,
"Wait, is this what happiness
feels like?
[ Laughter ]
I like it."
Unfortunately,
the Jets are owned
by Johnson & Johnson,
which means Rogers will only be
66% effective.
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Oohs and cheering ]
Better than nothing.
And, hey, everyone is excited
about this --
tomorrow kicks off the first
round of March Madness!
[ Cheering and applause ]
Now, I read that the odds
of picking a perfect bracket
are one in 9 quintillion.
[ Murmuring ]
Yeah, those are basically
the same exact odds
of me getting into Harvard.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of Ivy League schools,
I saw that 15 seed Princeton
made it to the tournament
and they got to play
Number 2 Arizona.
[ Oohs ]
Yeah, it's pretty
lopsided matchup,
but the Princeton fans
still have school spirit.
Check out some of the signs
they made for the game.
The first one says...
[ Laughter ]
This next one says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
And, finally, this one says...
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
They came to win!
Go, Princeton.
Yep, March Madness
is almost here
and there are so many
amazing players
in the tournament this year,
but I noticed that,
if you combine some
of their names,
you can create an even
more interesting player.
I'll show you what I mean.
For instance, if you combine...
...you get...
[ Laughter and applause ]
You want a Pringle?
If you combine...
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
If you combine...
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
Next up, if you combine...
[ Laughter and applause ]
And, finally, if you combine...
["Deez nuts"]
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
-You got there.
-Dease Nates!
["Deez nuts"]
What! is going on?
Some entertainment news --
due to high budget concerns,
Netflix is no longer
moving forward
with Nancy Meyers'
$130 million romantic comedy.
-Oh.
[ Awws ]
-But I know what's going
to happen -- any minute now,
Netflix is going
to realize they messed up
and run to catch Nancy Meyers
at the airport.
[ Laughter ]
"Hold the doors!
Hold the doors, Nancy!
I've made the biggest mistake
of my life.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
We're going to make that movie."
Some business news --
I heard that Delta Airlines
is now offering espresso
martinis on their flights.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Flight attendants were like,
"That's what we needed --
drunk people with energy."
[ Laughter and applause ]
And finally, I just heard
about a new survey that said
over 53% of all Americans
are big Taylor Swift fans.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Well, apparently,
the music industry
is putting out this kind of data
all the time,
so I thought we'd take
a look at some of it now.
It's time for "Tonight Show
Pie Charts."
Here we go.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ The Roots playing
ethereal tune ]
-"Pie Charts."
♪♪
Just look at some of these.
First up, when asked...
[ Cheering and applause ]
Interesting.
Here's another one.
When asked...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Up next, when asked...
[ Cheering and applause ]
d4vd JVKE...
-I...
-...!
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Next up, when asked...
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Oh.
-Interesting.
Next, when asked...
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
Where he hears that new music.
-Wow!
Wow!
-♪ Let's go to the hop ♪
-♪ Oh-bah-bah-bah ♪
-♪ Oh, baby ♪
-♪ Bah-bah-bah-bah-bah ♪
-♪ Let's go to the hop ♪
-Up next, when asked...
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
-[ Slurring ]
I'mma do it one more time.
[ Laughter ]
I can do it better.
When asked...
[ Cheering and applause ]
There you have it.